- Tim is the worst.
The other day he like
saw me eating my apple
and he was like, "Oh, you
don't cut your apple first?"
- "Oh, I'm Tim, I don't
do any of my own work
"because I'm a jerk."
- Yeah, the other day
he asked me to like...
- [Voiceover] Oh God, I shouldn't have
made fun of Tim like that.
What if someone in the
coffee shop heard me
and is friends with him?
What if I get fired because he finds out
what I said?
He's probably a good guy
once you get to know him.
I bet he just has a tough time at work.
- Here's your change, $2.00.
Have a good day.
- Awesome, thank you.
Have a good one.
- [Voiceover] They gave
me the wrong change?
Should I take it?
What if I get arrested
and imprisoned for life?
All because I decided
to take an extra dollar
from this gentle mom-and-pop shop?
- No, no.
You know what, no.
I'm sorry.
You gave me three
dollars, not two dollars.
And I was going to take it.
I was gonna (bleep) take it.
Here, take this.
Take it.
You know what?
Actually, no.
You deserve all of my money.
I'm a terrible person.
I'm so sorry.
- [Voiceover] Oh my God.
I can't believe I did that.
She's gonna hate me for that.
Oh God.
- I am so sorry.
I don't even know.
I'm so sorry.
So so sorry.
- [Voiceover] Oh God,
everyone knows it was me
who spilled the milk.
Look at them staring at me.
- I spilled the milk.
I did it.
- How are you today?
- I'm good, Stephen, how are you?
- Oh, it's pronounced Ste-phan.
- Oh my God.
I'm so sorry.
Oh that must happen to you all the time
and I'm adding to that.
I'm really, truly sorry.
I'm really sorry about earlier Stephan.
Got it right that time. Ha!
I'm really sorry.
- Hey, Stephan,
we are closing.
Why haven't you started cleaning up yet?
- Oh, this woman dropped some straws
and she offered to clean the whole place.
- Hey!
Sorry again, yeah.
- Oh.
Cool.
(jazz music)
- I'm sorry, I'm sorry.
Sorry sink.